T'es rentré quand?
À 17h quand je t'ai envoyé le message.
D'accord.
Pourquoi t'as une croix dessinée sur ta main?
Ça?
C'est mnémotechnique.
Ça te sert à quoi?
Bah tu connais pas?
Généralement tu fais une croix pour te souvenir
que tu dois te rappeler de quelque chose.
C'est absurde.
Ça sert à rien de te rappeler que
tu dois te souvenir de quelque chose
si tu sais pas quoi.
Je suis pas con.
C'est pour ça que pour moi la croix
ça veut toujours dire la même chose.
C'est à dire?
Ben la croix ça veut dire:
Regardes dans ta main.
Il y a une flèche,
qui te montre ton avant bras.
«poche de gauche»
Ah oui.
La boîte aux lettres.
La boîte aux lettres?
C'est pas un peu long pour
juste se souvenir d'aller poster une lettre?
Poster une lettre?
Mais ça n'a rien à voir.
La boîte au lettre!
Le courrier est relevé à deux horaires différents.
16 h en semaine et 12h le samedi.
16 c'est P et 12 c'est L.
«PL».
«PL» ?
«Premier love».
Ma première histoire.
Le tatouage que j'ai sur la jambe.
«Marguerite»?
Ouais.
Mais «Marguerite» c'est aussi une pizza.
La pizza c'est l'Italie,
l'Italie c'est l'Europe,
l'Europe c'est l'Euro,
l'Euro c'est l'argent,
l'argent c'est sur mon compte,
mon compte c'est sur ma carte de bleue
qui est dans mon porte-monnaie.
T'as Cauet sur ta carte bleue?
Cauet il est Picard.
Picard c'est les surgelés.
Les surgelés, faut manger,
manger faire les courses.
Faut que je fasses les courses.
Aaaaah.
Et comment tu fais pour
te rappeler de ce que tu dois acheter?
Ben je fais des listes comme tout le monde.
Ah ben oui.